oh
right
sorry it's been a long couple of weeks
first amd announced their new radeon and
verizon products were released yesterday
and then nvidia decided they were going
to announce super on the second and
well let's just say i've been putting in
some extra hours
but it was well worth it the new radeon
rx 5700 series is nearly as interesting
as the new 3rd gen ryzen processors
a ridge wallet is a sleek way to keep
wallet bulge down thanks to its compact
frame and rfid blocking inner plates use
the offer code in the video description
to save 10 on your ridge wallet and get
free worldwide shipping
[Music]
first the cards themselves we've got
three skus available at launch the
mid-range rx 5700 is positioned to
compete directly against team green's
rtx 2060 while the higher end rx 5700 xt
with four extra compute units was being
pitted against the rtx 2070 but now that
card is out of the picture so the real
rival there ends up being the rtx 2060
super
finally there is a limited edition 50th
anniversary rx 5700 xt with a gold
trimmed shroud and an 80 megahertz clock
boost for an extra 50
personally i'd buy an extra game but
everyone has different priorities
powering the rx 5700 series is a new
seven nanometer core design amd is
calling rdna
compared to the previous generation gcn
based cards like vega our dna features
native pci express 4.0 support along
with gddr6 as standard not hbm2 as a
result of the latter point availability
should improve over vega and the
financial break-even point for emd
should be far lower giving them more
mobility in terms of pricing an
important point we'll get to later on
for now i want to nerd out a little bit
the new compute units are core to the
performance and efficiency gains amd
claims with the rx 5700 series
and ultimately may be a point of
contention for amd fans because of what
it implies about the amd
fine wine technology
see a gpu typically does its work in
batches to make a long story short each
of amd's older gcn compute units can
work on up to four batches at a time and
wouldn't you know it each batch is sized
to be evenly divisible by four thanks to
the magic of parallel processing that
means it can complete one batch per
cycle if four cues are active
simultaneously which is where amd's
traditional strength in compute comes
from the problem with this approach
comes about when there's fewer than four
batches to work on simultaneously which
frequently occurs in games as processing
demands rise and fall depending on
what's on the screen so if you end up
having one batch getting processed at a
time it could take up to four times
longer to complete than it otherwise
would and even worse it's not because
the gpu is overworked but rather because
there's so much of it sitting idle
optimizing games and drivers to help
prevent this is somewhat complex and
also where many of those fine wine
improvements come from our dna compute
units on the other hand use two cues
each capable of handling batches at
twice the rate of gcn in a single cycle
which means each compute unit in the new
architecture can handle the same amount
of work as before but with only half the
potential for performance loss in an
unoptimized scenario all while being
easier to optimize for amd capitalized
on this new design by combining it with
a few other tweaks that help smooth out
the rough edges which altogether makes
for a far more streamlined and optimized
rendering engine for games with the
obvious downside for amd fans being that
fine wine as we know it may be a thing
of the past along with the hardware
amd's launching a host of new features
some of which are novel and while others
are
well let's get into it radeon's
multimedia capabilities got a
substantial boost this generation with
support for the new visually lossless
display stream compression technique
that enables the new cards to output up
to 8k60 off of a singles connector with
no chroma subsampling that's pretty sick
less cool sick and more
sick is the new radeon media engine that
combines encoding and decoding into one
place
on paper you've got the ingredients for
a really versatile card but our test
recordings were disappointing at the
same cpu usage and bitrate nvenk
completely wipes the floor with it with
many of the smaller details of our
recording just completely getting lost
on amd
ouch
perhaps the most interesting of the new
features is what amd is calling anti-lag
it's a little difficult to explain
exactly the tl dr is that you can think
of it kind of like a v-sync for your cpu
but unlike vsync it actually lowers
input lag
it achieves this by having the cpu only
tell the gpu to work on frames as soon
as they're needed meaning that while
frame rates might drop by a few
percentage points with it on
the time taken to display each frame
and thus the input lag is reduced linus
is caught the high speed camera bug so
let us know in the comments if you want
to see this put to the test and i'll
pass the feedback along i'm sure he'll
be down for any excuse to play with the
fandom again finally there's the feature
that's interesting for all the wrong
reasons
the new open source fidelity fx
framework
you can think of this a bit like
graphics tweaking packages like reshade
or sweet effects but virtually for free
contrast adaptive sharpening is what amd
chose to show off for now and
really i could take or leave it some
things look decent like the road in
motion example in f1 2019 but others
look really tacky like their borderlands
example
the good news is that it comes without a
performance penalty so if you do like it
you can toggle it on for all dx9 12 and
vulcan titles via the radeon image
sharpening feature bringing us finally
to benchmarks
since i've been on such a time crunch
for this release i'm reusing the gpu
bench i built up for the nvidia super
video which thankfully means i can also
reuse some of those numbers
that's the one benefit to product
launches this close together
there's no time for driver updates
[Laughter]
amd's off to a good start in gaming
though the rx 5700's performance has it
competing well against even the rtx 2060
super and at times its bigger brother rx
5700 xt overtakes even the far more
expensive rtx 2070 super
titles with hair works like metro exodus
gave us lower performance on radeon but
the new lineup still remained
competitive against its direct
competitors typically sitting above
their overall performance levels
not a great look for nvidia right now
considering super was supposed to be a
giant middle finger to amd as for
productivity amd is still strong but a
bit more of a mixed bag than usual
for instance for longer renders in
blender both new cards beat out the rtx
but then in shorter ones both of them
lost even to the non-super rtx 2060.
we thought that was pretty weird sort of
interrupt future anthony here you might
have noticed something
strange about this blender result look
at the 2070 super it's way out of line
well i re-ran it a bunch of times on all
the cards and even though the 2070 super
isn't that far ahead of the 2070 and
other tests here we are
still investigating this one okay on to
the video then luxmark has team red and
team green trading blows again depending
on the workload
both amd cards steal the show in catia
and solidworks even from the rtx 2070
super and as for the rest of spec view
perf we've got another mishmash of wins
and losses for team red and team green
with the deltas being high enough that
depending on your workload you might opt
for one over the other one last bit of
performance testing pci express 4.0
we weren't expecting much in terms of
performance uplift here and that's
exactly what we got
at least with these workloads i mean
some games see a couple of extra frames
and these spec view perf numbers are a
little bit higher but
that's about it as for thermals
well the good news is it could be worse
but the bad news is that it's only true
because it hasn't caught fire yet the rx
5700 seems fine but it looks like there
are some early teething issues with the
rx 5700 xt that caused our unit to boost
itself into oblivion and overheat
eventually shutting down under certain
conditions
like sitting in a game menu for too long
these kinds of lapses in qa testing are
exactly why we get upset when
manufacturers like amd
rush things to market rather than
waiting until they're fully cooked
pardon the pun the lightest maybe say
that anyway assuming they can squish
this bug and tame the beast the value
proposition is an interesting one on the
one hand nvidia's rtx 2070 non-super is
probably going to be a pretty good deal
in the near future as stores get rid of
stock to make room for super
but the rtx 2060 super being a slower
card plays into amd's hand here
they targeted their rx 5700 xt at the
2070 and it's now priced like a 2060
super
it may not win on all fronts and if
nvidia's objectively better software and
feature suite mean nothing to you then
the rx 5700 series
often manages superior performance per
dollar in gaming and for productivity it
trades blows enough that it'll be worth
it for many especially linux and apple
users who enjoy superior driver support
from amd
so
early adopter issues aside it's not the
groundbreaking industry shaker upper
that ryzen 3rd gen is where amd
dismantled intel's entire consumer
product lineup
but it's worth buying which is honestly
more than we expected given how much of
amd's gpu division has defected to intel
in the last couple of quarters one thing
that concerns us though is
where do they go from here it's tough to
see how amd will release a higher end
card with this architecture without
resorting to liquid cooling
and five nanometers is unlikely to tame
the inferno but
today's a happy day
let's deal with that problem tomorrow
and today can be your happy day thanks
to mass drop and the sennheiser pc37x
gaming headset
its open back design gives you a wide
stereo image from drivers that come from
the venerable hd 598 and hd 600
headphones
you'll get clearer audio for gaming and
music and for comms you get a noise
cancelling microphone optimized to
handle unpleasant pops and hisses that
automatically mutes when you rotate it
out of the way
best of all its 10 foot braided cable is
strong enough and long enough to reach
around even the most elaborate gaming
setup buy today from drop.com at the
link below
thanks for watching guys if this video
sucked you know what to do but if it was
awesome get subscribed hit that like
button or check out the link to where to
buy some of the stuff we featured in the
video description maybe not the 5700 xt
right now but the 5700 should be fine
and also linked in the description is
our merch store where you can get cool
shirts like this one and also this
hoodie and our community forum which you
should totally join